the South was trying to use the dispatch
now they clear it out for hey with you
go one-on-one nice crossover Kyrie
latrine
take a look it's Hayward trying to
utilize the mismatch and at Kyrie are
the preliminary loose picked up by kept
on
[Applause]
throwing up rookie look how far he and
then reach get that ball here falling
into the fourth quarter would be nice oh
[ __ ]
[Applause]
Kim was gonna fire out of town what a
first half for Kemba Walker stair
Magruder down little shimmy before he
pulls up and he knows it's down here
comes Kyrie approaching the halfway mark
second quarter so Kyrie in the paint
good pass
Oh Shelley for two
take a look at Kyrie putting the heat on
the defense they're retreating
and when Kyrie gets in the paint loose
ball
Tatom wow what an effort
timba one-man-show look three Raptors
around him he spins and then fades away
over the top take a holiday
[Music]
[Applause]
in this corner alone to Milwaukee boy
who the neg fires dating back to the end
of the second quarter the Hornets are
Arnhem 11 Oh Ron
nice pants on the inbounds who set up a
bucket of over the hole
[Applause]
or a great cut-rate pass and finished
concentration by the all-star Boston in
control early Irene right here at these
point up to the three the inside out
gets to the basket hangs in the air
Wow it starts with Tim buck
JJ reddick on it crosses him over draws
contact star ass no foul somehow but
score the goal of Kimmel Walker to shoot
that ball wow he's getting hit on the
waist right there and beam hits him on
the weight
[Applause]
Butler thinks he's got it a quick step
back high over the top of Butler
I read
he hypnotizes two guys
[Applause]
the best get ourselves a timeout
Kairi just mesmerizes everybody and
there's a little bounce pest abating
Kemba has mere touch on it slides inside
just a moment ago he showed you what
he's all about somehow getting it past
one of the best shot blockers in the
world growing it up on the backboard and
through him but doing his snake he's got
Lions on skates dentist
man on skates I would just go for the
first bake and leave alone figure out
what they're gonna do cos filling into a
player for 45 days and expect him chance
for a four-point play that I have to
hurry up on way that were out on the
Raptors before it came down curving able
to blow by on the sidelines
Kyrie oh what a pass
with tyreme a light hold true moment
Kyrie could have pulled it out no way
we're pushing it we're going to go on
three hard push by Kyrie over to Tatum
for the jam and a three point lead with
thirteen point nine to go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
deep three
a back and answer Kairi said I got some
for you mr. wall I'm just gonna pull up
from deep
oh sweet sweet
serving it for you I read to the basket
just throw it up for lob Williams
Oh put your head by the rim young fella
except the dribble of four seconds to
shoot Kemba slides his side free throw
jumper and the Hornets all-time leading
scorer gets the end the roll he's worthy
because Butler with doggett defense on
Irving Kyrie kept his dribble alive
tough shot
watch this shot watch as he gets down in
here he doesn't have anything but now
I'm gonna go right up with a little fade
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful spin move right there by Kyrie
again we have two of the top five point
guards of the game going at it we just
heard Chris a little talk about he waved
everyone away so he could get the
penetration good job my tights to get
back in the play that time and get the
deflection Rivers try the lava to compel
we got a good one go and get some
popcorn baby behind the back Kimmel
Walker back on the floor Ken Buck got
green up in the air just got crushed by
green and he hits the shot how did he do
that on step in a good ball fake and
it's a three
oh absolutely Hornets in a hurry
Marvin back to Kemba 1.9 and you're
worried about getting running out of
building right teams over the years have
tried to use their altitude to their
advantage but not this year's 100
Kemba most acrobatic layup of the year
boards switched hands rock the cradle
finished with the left hand
breaking ankles that's what it's called
cross it over
hang split and the Hornets get into the
backcourt kimba's got it they can't
catch him the Hornets a winner on a
Sunday night
[Applause]
it didn't count it was after the buzzer
but what a way to put an exclamation
point on a w that's react pretty well
defensively smart underneath Kyrie 2 on
the shot clock
crazy annually hit that shot shot clock
down to one can pass to fire straight on
three this guy's seen a really good ball
for three and pretty good passer even
though
[Applause]
big time shot maker great contest by
Leonard you're just looking at an elite
offensive player
[Music]
to the corners Khalistan through it
where he was
[Applause]
it's in the words my man - a huh just
time and score and nobody does the best
then the point guards in this league
flash down by the two
[Applause]
well buddy man ball Charlie get the kids
to fight over the hill I did go away
scammer the guy beat China basket
[Applause]
from it magical display we saw the other
night against Toronto look at this play
Mike off the dribble doesn't even put
the second hand on it I mean on target
and on the money playing so well the
team is winning and it gets your
attention that gets you folks how about
that always been good at driving the
ball going the other side and rim
remember the NCAA tournament he had from
our captain turned it over Kyrie
it's impasse again the field for for for
next week
shot clock at four Irving on the drive
gonna have to force it up to gets it off
the timing back to down 19 points for
Kyrie over I mean this is just
tremendous defense and the ability to
stay up short-handed the three players
involved in the deal not in uniform yet
Irving slams at home with two hands what
pretty dime by Jason Tatum at the
switching the pick and roll
Irving and one he got juicy got sauce he
has it all worked in tonight right there
about to fill the deep Bronco gets back
potatoes nice with the rebound and
Rozier comes out of the backcourt of
look for Irving goes
[Applause]
pass deflected
Kemba still reach our exit through the
hood
another bucket for the bonus he's got 20
or it's gonna have to fire another half
[Applause]
Angelo Russell I want to read into that
I don't think Kenny Hanson Kenny I could
sit like that quick shot Wow Kimba
scores and I think what happens is
everybody's watching those things so I
got to be able to coach you and tell you
what you're not getting it done on a
beautiful advance feed from smart being
his ability to handle the basketball so
skill
beautiful move in transition avoiding
Caruso
there's guy but these are the moves he
made into playgrounds but you can't let
it go I'm not gonna let you get away
with saying that black from behind you
just overall you look you look at Caruso
you look at Williams you look at vogner
didn't Larry Bird one get game say he
was gonna just make every shot
left-handed and that's what he actually
did and did it against the Portland
Trail was tiring with another
three-pointer Williams had a hand that
is faced by far their most productive
quarters and they have relied on briefs
the first time huh
who writes a notional post up look at
that tough shot yeah the quarterback
Kimber Wolcott serialize they'll catch
the first round I'll know the signs stop
argue my gets it off then time it
switches it good on pizza first at Fort
Campbell walk any tire basketball games
is the double team and any time he's
played in a screen and roll game and all
these shots have been like that a
contested Greek Kemba now has seven
points
no Bulldog defensive player to make the
stops
Irving back to Horford Horford for three
ties the game
[Applause]
gilma Walker what's the true looking to
make a deal to somebody else namely
Kyrie Irving Irving to the basket Kirby
a second to go drive it the couple they
pick at it as the angle heads
[Applause]
[Music]
duck quacks and Wanda
[Applause]
just came up the loose ball shot clocks
at for Hornets gonna have to put
something up on the Rama
[Applause]
in that one halfway down bathes the
rebound
Jason zeroed on twenty nine and ten days
years every rattles him along three he
was about three feet beyond the arc into
the basket how about that one that one
no doubt about it tire be free to shoot
puts it in as a shot clock expires
Joseph is draped all over and it's
nothing but the bottom of the net then
clock and shot clock one winding down
the first ten o'clock Dominic's will
defender Irving his hands the tribes of
[Music]
good shot by Kyrie Irving seen by your
big sabonis to Turner what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content